- Des policiers escortent le
rédacteur en chef de Stand News
à l'extérieur de l'immeuble
qui abrite le site web
pro-démocratie.
Puis, ils effectuent
des perquisitions dans
les locaux de la publication.
Les autorités accusent
ses responsables d'encourager
la sédition, d'avoir publié
des articles incitant au mépris
du gouvernement hong kongais.
"Ne soyez pas biaisés", lance
ce haut gradé de la police, qui
se défend de cibler les médias
lors d'une conférence de presse
pour expliquer l'opération.
Depuis la vague de
manifestations pro-démocratie
il y a deux ans, la Chine veut
consolider son emprise sur
Hong Kcien territoire
britannique qui lui a été
rétrocédé. La répression s'est
accentuée. Une centaine de
militants ont été arrêtés
e coup d'une nouvelle
loi protégeant la sécurité
nationale.
La fermeture de Stand News
s'ajoute à celle du Apple Daily,
un quotidien critique du régime
chinois, qui était lui aussi
dans la mire des autorités.
Il a été imprimé pour la
dernière fois en juin dernier.
"Çe que Hong Kong se
retrouve maintenant sans médias
indépendants du gouvernement",
dénonce la directrice d'un
groupe canadien qui appuie
vement pro-démocratie.
Une Canadienne se retrouve
d'ailleurs parmi les personnes
arrêtées lors de l'opération
contre Stand News : la chanteus,
qui a déjà résidé à Montréal.
Voici ce qu'elle disait
en juillet 2019.
"Nous sommes tous en danger à
Hong Kong. Nous sommes sur le
point de devenir une autre ville
chinoise où nous perdrons toute"
"Nous espérons que
le gouvernement fédéral viendra
en aide à Denise", dit-elle.
Son groupe craint que
les Canadiens vivant à Hong Kong
ne soient plus e
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M